spontanément ma sensibilité - elle va
vers la protection animale vers la
protection des espèces vers la
protection de l'environnement j'ai été
parlementaires européens écologistes et
c'est vrai que j'ai un engagement je
pense que on va dans le mur si on
continue à produire à consommer à vivre
comment le fait globalement globalement
donc je suis plutôt
je suis plutôt sur les changements de
paradigme quand j'ai dit ça est ce que
le changement de paradigme peut-être une
injonction
réalisable avec un claquement de doigt
la réponse elle est non c'est pas
possible document les injonctions
irréalisable ça m'intéresse pas trop
faire bouger la société dans le bon sens
ça en revanche je pense que c'est le
rôle des citoyens que nous sommes et
pour le sport pour ce faire et je crois
que les parties en présence d'abord
s'écoute et se respecte et et peut-être
écouter un peu les arguments des uns des
autres ce que vous avez un peu de mal à
faire et c'est bien dommage parce que
ceux qui nous écoutent à mon avis
n'apprécie pas trop le bois celui qui
dit ceci est dit la chasse à courre par
exemple je suis totalement opposé
totalement
ou presque
il faut évoluer on a un million deux
cent mille chasseurs je crois actifs
c'est ce qu'on dit est ce que c'est un
million deux cent mille chasseurs
doivent être traité en bloc de manière
un peu essentialiser les chasseurs c'est
ça les chasseurs c'est ça moi je me suis
j'ai toujours combattu et
l'essentialisation et jeunes de banlieue
sont des dingues que les immigrés et
coûte à la france
les fonctionnaires sont en effet tout ça
était supportable je pense que dans les
chasseurs les chroniqueurs balance en
place par tous en même temps ça aussi
c'est faux parce que c'est pas mon cas
donc ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que
l'être tous les chasseurs dans
je dirais une même même considération
les mêmes approches même analyse je
pense que ça n'est pas juste il ya des
chasseurs qui sont soucieux de
l'environnement je le crois les
chasseurs qui sont soucieux de la
protection des espèces je le crois puis
un des chasseurs qui s'en foutent
royalement comment on fait pour faire
avancer le sujet je fais comparatif
avait l'agriculture si vous permettez on
est passé d'une agriculture intensive à
une agriculture que l'on souhaite
raisonner mais j'aimerais que l'on fasse
pareil valascia ce que si on est sur une
chasse intensive à certains aspects on
passe à une chasse raisonnée et pour sa
section régulateur il faut poser des
règles il n'y en a déjà ne faisons pas
croire que les chasseurs n'ont pas de
règles il ya des périodes pour chasser
il ya des espèces à ne plus chasser il y
a quand même des règles est insuffisante
je pense qu'on peut aller plus loin mais
ça le fera avec vous messieurs est avec
vous mais si avec g coire ne peut pas le
faire non non non parce que je suis
habilité en responsabilité je pense que
si les parties en présence se parle avec
avec écoute mais aussi un esprit de
responsabilité on ne peut faire avancer
le sujet on doit faire avancer le sujet
j'ai envie de vous dire que on doit
distinguer là aussi moi je connais alors
vous allez me dire dans les quartiers
nord de marseille ap hm de chasseurs
comme quoi les images et les
villageois qui s'appelle l'estaque à
marseille dans le vieux mans nice main
sur l'auteur de l'estac mais y en a qui
charge je les ai rencontrés moi un
moment donné parce que j'avais des
copains il faisait moins culturellement
c'est pas je suis pas proche de cette
pratique parce que souvent c'est un
atavisme on chasse aussi de père en fils
ou alors on a des copines qui vous
emmènera chasse où vivent dans des
milieux où ils achats donc c'est aussi
notre une forme de transmission moi je
n'ai pas bénéfice a donc j'étais curieux
j'ai été voir c'est pour ça que je vous
dis je peux pas essentialiser parce que
moi j'ai avec les chasseurs qui partait
le matin de queue pour aller se balader
en forêt avec leur chien qui tirait très
rare aux mains des fans les plus
inusités pas là pour faire disparaître
les espèces et puis en revanche y en a
peut-être qui sont à eux mêmes stars
mais y en a peut-être qui est qui qui
veulent effectivement
donc si vous reconnaissez qu'il faut
passer d'une chasse intensive à une
chasse raisonnée avec un peu plus de
régulation yoga c'est ce qui a une voix
pour qu'on interdise pas la chasse mais
pour que les parties en présence puis-je
y retrouver